Something that I don't get a lot is PR,
but today a PR package showed up on my doorstep,
and I think that this is going to be the best PR I've ever received.
We are starting off so strong with this adorable Ralph Lauren hat.
I think this is so cute. For fall,
we have this super cute Kate Spade tumbler.
It's giving
Coastal grandmother bag full of goodies from Bumble and Bumble.
I can't wait to try them all out on my hair.
J. Cruz sent these adorable bow earrings.
Do you know what I don't have?
Bow earrings. Do you know what else I don't have?
Any Tory Burch at all. Giving all of the beach vibes.
An MK Airpod holder.
Stop! They're pink
obsessed.
I'm sugared to my very core.
Tulsa Premium Outlets sent me my first coach.
This is adorable.
I can't wait to go shopping at the Tulsa Premium Outlets.
Hope to see you there!